[Music]
first of all I love this film it's a
great film
um and one of the things I don't know if
you've had this feeling but one of the
things that struck me about it like I
feel like you can tell within the first
like five or 10 minutes if you're in
good hands with a
filmmaker and immediately I just felt
like oh sh I'm going on a ride right now
like she knows what she's doing and you
know I guess my especially for a first
feature it's incredible um and so like
where did that I guess where did you get
your confidence where did that
confidence come from and how did you
know that this was going to be your
first
film well it's funny you mention that I
always felt like I had a delusional
sense of confidence most of my life um
but
um I yeah I mean I I'd say you know I am
a firsttime you know feature director
but I had been directing television and
I think I I uh
I was able to stumble on other people's
projects on other people's shows you
know be um and learn and really and
really get clear um about what kind of a
filmmaker I am and what kind of stories
I'm looking to tell so um I I took my
time with it I I took my time uh finding
the story and making sure that that this
was the story that needed to be told um
and I think um it it uh there were
scripts that I wrote um over the years
and and to be honest I just I kind of um
I I abandoned them because I just didn't
think they were good enough or I felt
like I could do better um so I I think
it was a very it was by torturing myself
I would say that that I eventually um
came to this script and and once I did
it was it was I just knew um in my gut
and I just I I could just feel it I
could feel it with this script more than
I'd ever felt with anything else I'd
written and um and um
and yeah I was just uh I think because I
I'd spent years kind of honing and
obsessing and obsessing um that by the
time I got to this this film I was just
ready to
go I'm almost scared to ask but where
did the inspiration for this come
from
men well leave it at
that um one of my like favorite favorite
sub genres of of film is like erotic
Thrillers of the 80s and 90s like Basic
Instinct Fatal
Attraction um but you know looking back
on them now with the benefit of
hindsight um those films were like a
reflection of a very like male anxiety
at the time with sort of like feminism
and the rise of powerful women in the
workplace and this really sort of flips
the script on that in a really
interesting cool way was that something
that you intentionally said set out to
do or was that something that
organically happened through the process
of developing
it so I for me like I set out to make a
thriller about power dynamics within a
relationship um that definitely has
crossovers to the erotic Thriller genre
you know that has crossovers even to the
psychological Thriller genre um but for
me like I didn't I wasn't interested in
you know um staying within the confines
of any particular genre and I didn't set
out to to kind of reinvent the erotic
Thriller genre in any way I just I had a
story that was burning inside of me um
and um and uh yeah I think for it was
just it felt like a story that hadn't
been told yet and I think it was um um
you know really it's like I write my
fears and um I write what I'm afraid to
confront or acknowledge or what I feel
ashamed of and um this was something
that um I was com really compounding for
for for many years and
um uh it uh yeah I think I think the in
terms of like the lens that I wanted to
tell the story through it was uh it was
always a thriller and it was kind of it
was interesting because when I was first
when I first wrote the script and I was
kind of figuring out how to pitch this
film I was calling it an emotional
Thriller you know on some level but you
know because my intention was to use the
genre to shine a light on an emotional
Terror that I feel like we all face but
we normalize um and and this was a
feeling that IID only ever felt when
watching uh films in the genre space um
because I just couldn't quite shake the
feeling of coming home and both fearing
the person I loved but also the person I
was becoming um and that's really what
drove me to to writing you know and and
making the film the way that I
did Alden that brings me to Alden um I
don't know I've known you for a little
while now I don't know if I've ever told
you this but I've been a huge fan of
your work ever since I saw you in Tetro
the Francis Ford Copa film uh you've
were so great in movies like hail Caesar
and uh Oppenheimer you've worked with so
many great filmmakers so you know you
know what it's like when you get sent a
great piece of material and when you
know you're you're in good hands so what
Drew you to this script when you first
got a hold of it what and what convinced
you that I need to work with
Chloe um a few things I mean first was
the material itself it was clear that
this uh writing
was um both really well constructed from
a story standpoint and also really
personal and really personal in a way
that felt really ambivalent it's
interest so I haven't been doing I
haven't done press for the movie till
today for like like seven months Chloe's
been doing it all her own so it's fun to
hear the answers for the first time um
but what you were just saying about the
person you were becoming and and the
person uh that you loved and and being
afraid of that read really clearly on
the page and that was something that I
liked about it which was that it was
very complicated and that um everyone
involved was having these very you know
intense complicated experiences
um and then the other thing was just uh
the um resolve that Khloe had so in the
original conversations we had about
doing the movie in what were a a pretty
spectacular set of uh setbacks when it
came to making it and and and having the
sets built and then having to pause and
all these things and her um composure
and sort of stalwartness and
determination and and and and uh um you
can feel when something's kind of ripe
on the vine and and that she felt that
and that there was that drive so um you
know you don't know what it's going to
be like on set I've worked with people
who were not first-time filmmakers who
uh had complete meltdowns on set and um
and so it it was all the more sort of
thrilling for Khloe to have the the
really pratal control that she had over
the set over the decision she was making
and over the the
process um Luke I hate to you know judge
the character but he's a pretty
unlikable character I think but I do
think that you managed to imbue him with
a sense of humanity like uh you know he
he felt very threedimensional at times I
felt bad for him even though I didn't
really want to um what is that process
like of modulating your performance to
make sure that you're not turning this
you know the antagonist of the film into
a sort of mustache twirly villain you
know how do you find that that
line uh I think that in the um the way
the story was built you knew things were
not going to go very well pretty early
and uh you and I knew I had to do some
pretty horrific things as this
character um and so um um you know my
job is to try to uh put myself in that
person's shoes as best I can you can't
always get all the way in but um I think
that
uh it was just clear that it was more
more it was better if this was a human
being and that was in the writing itself
um and then in the rehearsals that
became clearer and it was just clear
that had he been um you know just
consumed by sort of malice from the
first scene um it would be exhausting uh
so uh uh you know and I think it's more
interesting to study people like that a
sort of monstrous sociopathic person is
just you know an anomaly it's not that
interesting to me so how we're all sort
of complicit in giving uh too much
Indulgence to the worst sides of
ourselves is a lot more um I think
poignant and and speaks to you know it's
probably more helpful or something so
yeah I don't know some version of what I
just
said well I just want to add to I mean
what I loved about Alden when I talked
when we first spoke he never judged the
character and cuz if he came in already
judging the character I'm like that's
not a way into this movie and that's not
a very interesting version of the film
um and what we had always talked about
was and trying to lean into it was um
and I never judged it too when I when I
was like on set with him I never wanted
him to feel like I was judging the
character and when I was talking to him
I was like we were always talking about
how much pain he was in and the more
that we leaned into his pain you know
because he's not the feelings he's
having don't make him a bad guy you know
what he does with those feelings are not
acceptable you know and and but the
feelings themselves are not his fault
this is a societal systemic problem that
that raises boys to believe that
masculinity is an identity when it's not
it's an energy you know and and what I
really wanted to show with this
character was that Luke represents a
certain Generation Well really many
generations of men um caught in the
middle between wanting to adhere to a
modern feminist Society but still having
been raised on traditional ideas of
masculinity and like on the one hand he
adores Emily because she's intelligent
you know he adors her because she's a
killer but because of the way he's
raised there is this feeling like he
needs to get there first and what I knew
Alden he would be able to give me that
you know and and lean into the duality
of those emotions The Duality of of
loving her but also wanting to hurt her
at the same time and the complexity of
of of the struggle between those two
things and I just feel like he did that
on a level that that that um I could
have never imagined with any other
actor um let's talk about the ending for
a minute
um well let me back up one thing I love
about this film is the tone yeah act two
um I love the tone and I love it because
it really feels like anything can happen
at any moment you know I I think the
movie totally could have ended in a
blood bath like Fatal Attraction style
and I totally would have bought it
because there's this threat of violence
that's simmering underneath the entire
film um and that's sort of why I think
the ending works so well in my opinion
it feels unexpected um how did you
arrive there and how did you know that
was the right way to go and was there
another version at one point that you
sort of were like this doesn't quite
feel
right so for me I I kind of I knew the
ending before I really knew the
beginning actually um but
um like I said I set out to make a
thriller about power dynamics between
men and women on the ugliest level so I
think to really talk about the ending
you have to talk about what happens in
the bathroom um
and for me the film always had to
escalate to sexual assault
because ultimately sexual assault is not
about sex it's about power and like I
said I wanted to do this on the ugliest
level um and that was the only way for
Luke to reclaim the power over Emily in
that moment is because he's physically
stronger than her um so because it
escalates to that then for me the ending
was well you know it's on Emily to
decide what she's going to do about it
um so for me the ending was always about
Emily reclaiming the power that luk
takes away from her um and and just
holding him out accountable um you know
and and for me it's like
uh it's uh it didn't have to get violent
if she if he had showed one sliver of
you know recognition or accountability
for the pain that he inflicted on her
but this is a man who's you know refuses
to to face that I mean that's what
causes all all the pain and and
Destruction for not only her but also
himself in the film like this is this is
something that he's running from um but
for me like the whole M the whole movie
really builds up to the line when she
gets him to say I'm nothing you know cuz
that's the moment that he finally
acknowledges his own infer inferiority
to her um and ultimately I think more
than being a film about female
empowerment this is really a film about
male fragility so that's where the film
needed to
end wow
um so good answer
um
uh how do I follow that
up SC frantically scrolling through any
pranks on
set
um okay here's one
um it's I you know just because the film
making process is so chaotic I think
it's rare that a film turns out exactly
the way that you planned it you know
when you first started out um which
sometimes I think can be for the best
because you get these happy accidents or
moments that looking back you're like oh
I never would have got that can both of
you point to something while making the
film that you sort of ort of discovered
in the process or that like sort of
looking back you're like oh I'm really
glad that horrible thing happened cuz we
wouldn't have gotten X or I wouldn't
have discovered this facet of the
character I can start um well a couple
things I will say people don't realize
but we shot this film just to start from
the production aspect we shot this film
in Serbia we I know you guys probably
got to the end credits and we read the
names and we're like what the like
where where did they shoot this um but
yeah we you know we made this film
independently this is an indie film and
um we went to Eastern Europe to because
we were able to put as much resources
you know on the screen as possible over
there and we were able to get the shoot
days over there that we wouldn't have
gotten in New York um with the budget we
had um so starting with that you know I
I would say in terms of expectations it
was
uh it was constantly because you're
working on a certain budget you're
constantly getting hit as you know every
day with like building costs for example
uh were just constantly going up um and
then the producers would come to me and
be like well you got to cut five more
pages or you got to you know condense
these locations or whatever so it was
just it was constant I feel like every
day was
just like
re you know just thinking about the film
in in a different way or how how can I
retain what what I want and what I
Envision while you know while getting
creative and and and protecting the you
know the film The Integrity of the film
itself but I would say one thing was
like a um uh I had to cut I had to cut
like this whole sequence with her when
she gets like a Lambo like there she
gets like a yeah they give her like this
ridiculous Lambo in like one of the um
the previous drafts and and she has this
this car that she doesn't want you know
it's this male fantasy version of some
of a toy that she doesn't want and then
she has to drive this thing drunk
through Chinatown try and park it and it
was like whole thing um but uh but uh
ultimately we couldn't afford that um
and so uh I was put in a corner and it
was like this whole thing and and my
producers were pacing and they were like
they were like we you know because I was
I was holding on to the lambo with like
everything I had um and uh but
ultimately being put in the corner I
just felt like it was that Spielberg
moment with like the you know when he
sees the shark um with jaws and it's
just like okay this looks ridiculous
what are we going to do now but then he
came up with the idea well if we don't
see it that's more terrifying but it was
only because the shark looked ridiculous
and wouldn't work you know but it was
kind of like the lambo was was that
moment for me where um where I just had
to simplify it and and it ended up being
the check and the check was was more
simple but it was straight to the point
um and uh and I just think ultimately it
was better for the
story yeah I was going to say Serbia
because we were fairly uh it was mostly
Serbian crew and what that meant was it
really intensified the sense of uh just
kind of us in the center of this and it
was really me and Phoebe and Khloe and
Men of the
DP really really doing this together and
we got a few days of rehearsal and got
to do all these you know Chloe you know
made that happen which was
fantastic um and so that was uh uh it
just helped kind of the intimacy and by
the time we got to filming the movie it
felt a little bit like Tetra my first
movie where we had um you know spent
these days together playing out like the
first time we said I love you to each
other or her first day on the job and
I'm giving her a tour of the office and
there was this trust built um in advance
of shooting that then was really
helpful I feel like it's so rare these
days to have that rehearsal time how do
you like to run a rehearsal you know
just like what does that look like for
film because we I think we know we kind
kind of Imagine a play rehearsal but a
film is very different CU it's so
fragmented so how do you how do you even
set that
up um so I think I mean given the nature
of this film it's it's really confined
to these two locations um the apartment
and the office um which was intentional
the idea is that they can't escape each
other you know they're kind of stuck
between these two claustrophobic uh
spaces and and that's part of what leads
is such an explosive you know Final Act
is is that it is becomes this toxic
bubble that's just ballooning um but uh
so because of that um I think it just
worked out we were kind of Lucky cuz we
had this those sets built um and we were
able to rehearse um on the actual sets
um we had a week um just just the three
of us and and that was uh that was
something that I told my producers from
the beginning I said I said this is the
most important thing because uh I'm
never going to make a movie without
rehearsals like I don't understand
directors that go in and and I mean good
for them but like I wouldn't be able to
sleep I wouldn't I just I feel like it's
not only a bonding time with your actors
but um you run into problems you run
into things that don't work you know and
how can to find out all these problems
on the day of and I just don't know how
you make your days or you know just
stuff like that but um having the
rehearsal time it was we were able to
discover things and have time to
discover things and and Implement those
discoveries in a way that that that
still kept us on on schedule and and um
and uh where when we got to the day of
filming we were able to do 10 takes and
uh you know or sometimes maybe more and
get to play and uh where Alden gave me
you know 20 different shades of a scene
and we just like that that was um that
was because we rehearsed and um so uh I
basically we had time for about 80% of
the to rehearse about 80% % of the
scenes I think and um and uh so we just
we would just you know read through the
words kind of run them in half speed we
had an intimacy coordinator there from
the beginning um and uh it was I yeah it
was just it was really the greatest the
greatest experience and uh yeah the
greatest
joy I was going to ask about the
intimacy coordinator of it all but they
said I have five minutes left so I feel
like we should end on a more positive
note um
but uh you kind of had one of those like
fairy tale Sundance moments that I think
everybody kind of dreams about or maybe
if you if you watched Entourage that you
kind of have seen a version of portrayed
uh where your film you know debuts to
rapturous reviews and you sell to a yeah
I think it was a it was a um
disorienting um yet magical weekend uh
that was all pretty much a blur but uh
the the the first screening we had was
Friday afternoon so I was kind of right
out of the gate and we intentionally
didn't want to have our movie on any
lists or like we just kept it really
under the radar we didn't do any press
before we wanted the film we wanted
people to discover the film for
themselves um and uh our our screening
was at the library and it was uh I have
to say the first like five minutes I was
I was dying
because they put us you know because
they give the the buyers the best seats
right in the front and whatever so they
put us all the filmmakers by this giant
fan you know in the back where you know
with ushers going in and out every 20
seconds and you're there and it's like I
I killed myself to make this movie you
know this this is my moment you're like
I it's not loud enough the film's not
loud like what this there's no these
people are going in and out is anyone
paying attention you know what I mean
but I will say as soon as the blood he
came up with the blood on his face and
the laughter in the room and then and
then from there it was like it didn't
matter that there was this giant fan in
my ear just driving me nuts
because because the rest of the audience
was in it and I will say that's that
screening was just the best like I mean
it was honestly Bonkers and I would say
one of the more batshit crazy screenings
we had because people were just like
laughing you know just out of discomfort
efort and and wooing and booing like
when she when she breaks the bottle over
his head they broke out into Applause
and then at the end when she says her
last line everyone started whistling I
mean it was just a crazy screening um
but I think what was uh so coming out of
it I was upset because I'm like that
sounded like I work so hard in the
sound design what the you know but
I I was I was feeling the energy of that
room and um and the reactions was like
okay people are feeling what I intended
them to feel and there was nothing
better than that feeling um obviously
the reviews and all the stuff that came
out after was like they started rolling
in and um and yeah was you could tell
people were already instantly wanting to
talk about this film which was
incredibly exciting um I will say that
one of the stranger parts of the whole
experience was trudging through the snow
going to different condos of of as
people pitch you know as as as we were
getting you know offers in for the movie
and you you're trying to find uh you
know like Netflix's cabin and you're
trudging through the snow and and and uh
and then then you go and you sit in the
cabin and you get the pitch and then you
trudge through the snow and you find
someone else's cabin and um and this was
in between you know press and all that
stuff so it it it's it's a it's a wild
bizarre experience but but it was it was
it was incredible I think I slept three
hours the whole weekend but it was it
was
amazing okay last question um I usually
hate this question question but I I'm a
fan so I want to know what's next for
both of
you uh uh what is next uh I'm uh doing
Festival circuit for this uh 15-minute
film I directed called Shadow brother
Sunday um oh thanks um I uh uh uh I
haven't answered this question in so
long and everything that was next is now
out um Iron Heart Marvel series comes
out TBD uh and then I'm doing a movie in
the in January that I can't talk about
but um that's it oh and then um uh I'm
going to be doing uh I have a theater
space called the hon station playhouse
that we're going to do our first play in
in
March and I'm writing another crazy
movie so get
ready uh thank you both so much the film
is so great and I I hope it wins a
million Awards um thank you for having
me thank you so much thank you for
coming appreciate
[Music]
it